you see they're taking our heritage away  that's not going to happen who is not  going to happen  and we were doing so well until the  rigged election happened to come along  we were doing really well but today that  Heritage is under threat  like never before  who would have thought this could have  happened even Bernie Sanders is saying I  never thought this could happen  he's mild by comparison yeah  Joe Biden has brought our country to the  brink of ruined respect a bunch of  malarkey the epicenter of a border and  migration crisis unlike anything anyone  has ever seen before that's a bunch of  malarkey  at the same time they have totally  obliterated your energy industry I told  you  under my Administration we achieved a  historic reduction in illegal  immigration